قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
في منتدى دافوس انه يجب ان تكون هناك سلطه
فلسطينيه خاضعه للاصلاح واعتبر ان اي سلطه
فلسطينيه لا تجد الدعم من الاسرائيليين لن
تستطيع تقديم ما يتطلبه الامر لايجاد
شراكه بين الطرفين بحسب
تعبيره نتحدث عن امرين هما اداره وهيكل ح
يعززان فرص السلطه لتحقيق مرام وتطلعات
الشعب الفلسطيني كما ان هذه السلطه ينبغي
ان تتمكن من العمل في بيئه صعبه وبدعم من
اسرائيل وليس فقط بدعم من المعارضه
النشيطه لانه حتى اقوى سلطه واكثرها
فعاليه ستجد نفسها في ورطه اذا ما اضطرت
للتعامل فقط مع المعارضه في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وينضم الان الينا من دافوس
مراسلنا عبد الله الشامي اهلا عبد الله
اذا هذه التصريحات لبلن ك عن سلطه
فلسطينيه تقبل بها اسرائيل كشرط اساسي لاي
شراكه ما دلالتها ما اهميتها وضعها لنا في
سياقها لو
سمحت نعم ليلى ربما يمكن ان نقول ان
بلينكن الذي لم يتحدث كثيرا اليوم عن
الوضع في غزه رغم الجلسه التي اقتربت من
ساعه يعني تحدث اكثر عن ما قال انه الحاجه
من قبل الاسرائيليين الى القبول بما قال
انها الصوره الاكبر التي لازالت سانحه وهي
تطبيع دول عربيه واسلاميه معهم وان من
يقرر ذلك اي اذا كانت هناك سلطه في
اسرائيل قادره او جاهزه لهذا الامر هم
الاسرائيليون الذين يمكنهم كما قال ان
يختاروا السياسيين الذين يمكنهم المضي
بهذا الطريق لكن في ذات الوقت لم يتحدث
ربما كما كان متوقعا بتفصيل اكثر عما يجري
في غزه قال قائلا او مكتفيا بوصف ما يحدث
هناك بالامر الموجع و وعادا مره اخرى الى
ما يتعلق بما قال انه المشاهد المؤلمه
التي او الالم النفسي كما اسماه الذي
شهدته اسرائيل في السابع من اكتوبر مشيرين
الى انه هناك العديد من الدول والاماكن
حول العالم التي لا زالت حتى اللحظه كما
قال ترفض اصلا الاعتراف بما حدث في هذا
اليوم حديثه عن السلطه الفلسطينيه هو في
سياق الكلام عن امكانيه وجود مستقبل بين
الطرفين قائلا ان هناك حاجه الى ان تكون
هناك سلطه اكثر فعاليه او اكثر ربما كفاءه
في امكانيه تقريب وجهات النظر لكن ذلك كما
قلت في متن الخبر لن يكون ممكنا الا اذا
تلقت الدعم المطلوب من الاسرائيليين وهو
بذلك ربما رمى الكره في ملعب الاسرائيليين
كما قلنا في تقرير الخطوات القادمه التي
يريدونها سئل بلينكن كذلك عما اذا كان كما
يرى الكثيرون حياه الاسرائيلي
اهم من الفلسطينيين وغيرهم او وجهه النظر
التي قال مدير هذه الجلسه انها ربما
منتشره في المنطقه قال ان الامر ليس صحيحا
وان ما يظهر من غ من غزه كما اسماه مشاهد
موجعه لكنه في ذات الوقت ربما تحدث عنما
او او استمر في الحديث عنما اسماه الصوره
الاكبر الممكنه رغم كل الاحداث في المنطقه
تحدث عن انه يمكن العمل رغم كل ما جرى على
ايجاد سلام عادل ودائم وتحقيق الوله
فلسطينيه لكن كما قلت لن تكون هذه الدوله
ممكنه او متاحه الا بوجود طرف اسرائيلي
يقبل التعاون ووجود شراكه مع الفلسطينيين
اشكرك جزيلا عبد الله الشامي من دافوس